[Music]
hey guys
welcome to japan just kidding
we are at the um asian studies building
at ubc in vancouver and
um we were actually just walking around
and
we stumbled across this really beautiful
building that i'd never seen before
and so i just wanted to take you guys
around
um i don't we don't have access to the
inside but
we can still walk around the outside
because it's very
serene and calm and ingrained in nature
and
yeah it's a nice nice little building so
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
so this building was built in 1975 and
it was designed by
an architect called donald matsuba
and it was actually a gift from the
japanese government
for the expo 70 and
the building represents a close
relationship
between japan and canada and
one of the really unique things about
this building
is that it reflects
the style of a japanese pagoda
and so you can see that with the metal
roof and
the skylight that pokes up at the top
and it's very low it has a pyramidal
shape
and one of the really unique things is
that it has a
reflecting pool all around the building
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
you